this is your first child that's so
exciting very exciting he was just you
know getting excited out there backstage
oh I do very well with the fetus they're
excited about Conan you know
congratulations it's it's a it's a
little it's interesting or it's ironic
because the character you play famously
on her maids tale is this woman who
cannot have a child yes
how long did you keep this a secret oh I
mean I you know they say you got to keep
a secret for the first three months to
make sure that everything's all safe and
sound and of course I tried to do that
but then the awful symptoms took over
and it was becoming difficult to sort of
hide that from everybody who's
interesting because a lot of women have
a different experience some women have
very few it's you know symptoms you say
you have bad symptoms you're talking
about like you not sick to your stomach
nausea I mean I was sick to my stomach
nausea I I really despise vomiting so I
managed to kind of get away from that
but there was you know there's all kinds
of stuff like I started to get really
nauseous and like saliva around my
husband which is apparently a thing
because I ended up going online and
googling a bunch of pregnancy forums and
women women's doctor gag around their
husbands because they can no longer
stand the smell of them which is exactly
what happened to me so apparently my
wife's been pregnant for a while 16 16
years apparently
no it's is that is that true because I
have heard of that before that it's
something hormonal where the the scent
of the husband physically makes you ill
and his repulsive yes it repulsed me he
he basically smelt like rotten oysters
to me for about three whole months and
then I just didn't want to have anything
to do with him it was mainly up here I
just I couldn't his face and his mouth
breath and things like that just wasn't
attractive to me anymore did you ever
worry that this would last forever
like that this was just a change that
for the RET your your husband would
become old oyster breath for the rest of
his life that were you at all you know
no you know I I didn't want to think
that way cuz that would be really rough
yeah
divorce yeah that happened no now we
have this yeah that's complicated
it's very complicated yeah it will it
will change there are all these things
that I women go through and trust me no
one knows women better than me a lot of
things the woman goes through that then
change afterwards after the baby is born
so I'm sure he he'll go back to because
you loved it he loved his you loved the
guy before right yes and now I know you
guys I now love him again it just it
just went away for a while yeah
you